girovani and Chandra Bose
thank you so much
before we start just a quick reminder my
friends no phone calls during the
interviews and if you can refrain from
broadcasting and recording your audio
during interviews that would be
wonderful really appreciate it and also
friendly reminder no photo or video all
right let's start with number 213 and
then move on to 277.
yeah two sevens hello right here uh
HIPAA Berry from Entertainment Tonight
congratulations
Namaste uh what does this feel like
taking it back to India the motherland
yeah it feels like uh like a just a sang
my most favorite song just a while back
it feels like top of the world
standing on the top of the world and I'm
really feeling uh feeling very proud for
my country and my the whole team who
just dedicated their energy and time for
this song including Mr Chandra Bose
thank you yeah
all right two seven seven and then three
yeah aquately if I'm wrong but there are
pictures in the Telugu language correct
that's right that's right
thank you that has
56 letters
so Telugu has 56 letters we have lots of
words lot of Expressions lot of feelings
in our language very great language and
very literary language very musical
language telugues if we write an
ordinary word it will sounds like a
music
so the in this song in RR Telugu lovers
will love the meaning but non-telugu
people like you people are loving the
song means this kind of sounding the
kind of music inside the song that make
this possible
all right we'll move on to three three
eight and then two eight four three
three eight yeah
yes yes please
yeah yeah hi
excuse me
thank you hi Nicolette Morales with
culture Focus Magazine congratulations
on your Oscar thank you very much that's
you made history tonight so I just want
to know how does it feel and what does
it mean to you personally to represent
your culture and and to make such a big
win with that amazing song what's going
through your mind I mean how does it
feel yeah right now I'm in Cloud Nine
and uh I feel very blessed to back this
kind of greatest recognition of the
world for my country for my culture for
my motherland and my for my movie
industry from Telugu language it feels
so great
the only thing running in in my mind now
present is I have to go to India I have
to I want to show this hour to my wife
and my children
thank you and
four followed by three
three yeah low right here uh right down
the middle uh Jonathan Landrum
Associated Press
right yeah right here
um I spoke to the both of you um you
know after you receive your nominations
um and I remember you spoke about
um you know bringing more recognition to
um other artists in India
um can you talk a little bit more about
that and how you just kind of Paving
away
um you know for others you know like
yourself yeah it's I feel this all about
it's just the beginning of everything so
so that the world particularly the
Western world uh focuses more on Indian
music and Asian music which is long due
and I I feel uh very happy but it is
like opening doors for the um
the world to embrace our culture and
music hereafter
three one four and three one four last
question
hello kirwani sir and John debriser
congratulations thank you very much
Sunil from American Kahani we spoke
before yeah
um what was the inspiration behind NATO
NATO
yeah not to Nato is the uh uh the pure
original uh cultural
genre of Indian music particularly South
Indian music which has lots of
percussions and The Rustic
texture of the music and to bring it out
with beautiful words written by Chandra
Bose and beautiful steps composed by our
choreographer Prem rat so it's a great
deal of teamwork which brought us this
far and to back this greatest award
and the lines I wrote in the song all
are my experience in my Village
thank you so much
Legend congratulations
[Applause]